We at Mozilla realized this. And we,
we saw JavaScript was something that you could compile to you.
As Adobe had somebody in the Adobe labs doing this too.
He had a project called alchemy. We had somebody who's now at Google. Um,
alone's a Chi who did his own LVMS compiler that would take C or C plus plus,
and it would emit JavaScript. And you would think this is crazy.
You're going from this sort of machine type, slow level fit, you know,
controlled memory allocation language to this garbage collected,
dynamically typed, uh, high level, higher level language,
but alone sort of just phenomenologically carved nature of the joint and
found the forms that were fast in JavaScript. And then with Dave Herman,
who I'd recruited from North Eastern university, who was the type theorist. And,
um, Luke Wagner is still at Mozilla, who was the compiler guy and the jet guy.
They figured out how to codify what Alan had done into a typed
subset of JavaScript called ASM JS.
And this is a strange thing to think about because it doesn't have new syntax.
The types are casts that occur in
dominator positions in the control flow graph.
So it's like a hack on JavaScript and it's a subset and it uses those Bitwise
operators that I talked about copying from Java to basically cast,
um, num numeric types. What's your double position flowing point into integers.
And so inside JavaScript in the kernel, semantics are integers.
And if you use these operators, if a compiler emits them in the right places,
you can then treat them as typed values type memory locations,
and you can type check your program and you can not only type check it.
You can compile it. And this is all in sort of linear time. Oh,
and you can compile it to have deterministic performance.
It doesn't touch the garbage collector.
It calls a bunch of functions that come from the C functions with C plus plus
code that you're compiling.
And you can make the Epic unreal engine go in 30
frames a second. And when we did this in 2013 in the fall, you know,
Tim Sweeney I'm at, um, didn't think he could be done quickly,
that it would take years. And the team went to Raleigh to Epic.
And in four days they had unreal engine ported by pressing a compile
button, right? They had the, but they had to have web GL,
which came from open shell IES came to open GL,
which came from Silicon graphics, jail. They had to have web audio.
So they could map open AAL,
which was another audio library standard to web audio,
which was kind of a Chrome idiosyncratic thing. Um, but they,
they could make it work and they had to have ASM JS for fast C plus plus to
JavaScript. And, uh, if you didn't have that fast compiler step,
the JavaScript you'd write by hand,
trying to do an unreal game would be too big and too slow. It would,
it would touch the garbage collector.
It will not keep up with 30 frames a second on the hardware, 2013 hardware.
So we demo that at, at, um, uh, this must have been fall 2012.
Now I think about it.
Cause we demoed it at GDC again to all the conference 2013 and people were
stunned. That's like unreal engine,
unreal tournament running in my browser window. No, plug-in no flash,
no Java. No.
So were those the early days of,
because JavaScript now is able to run basically on par with a lot of
the like C plus plus.
Yeah. And even before then you had the fast JavaScript VMs in 2008,
when Chrome came out just before it came out, Mozilla,
my friend undress gal and I, and others hacked out trace monkey.
Our trace based jet,
the squirrel fish extreme team at Apple did their Git.
And we were all competing on these crazy performance benchmarks.
It was a little bit too much tuning to the benchmark,
but JavaScript started getting fast and developers started noticing it,
but it was still kind of its own high-level language with garbage collection.
The ASM JS step helped us go further because until we really
proved the concept, people were still saying, well, JavaScript's okay.
It's getting faster. Thanks to VA. Everybody gave Google credit,
especially Google, but we need something to kill flash.
Let's use the portable native client code that Google had acquired native
client, um, which is a separate lineage for taking basically C code,
compiling it into a software fault,
isolated container of some sort of using some kind of virtualization technique.
And maybe it can even be in process and still know memory say,
that'd be awesome, but they ended up using process isolation too.
And that kind of weakened it. And in the end it was like portable native client.
Okay. You know, meet the new boss. Same as the old boss.
This is the Google flash. Right.
But when we did ASM JS and we showed unreal engine working,
I think it was only a matter of time before Google threw in the towel.
And in fact, everybody agreed in spring of 2015,
we're going to take what was proven by ASM JS and make a new syntax,
a binary syntax it's efficient that loads into the same JavaScript VM the
JavaScript blows into. So there'll be two source languages, one VM,
very important, one garbage collector, one memory manager,
one set of compiler stages. Uh, and that's called web assembly.
And that's the successor ASM JS.
And it's important that it have binary syntax because at the end of the day,
especially on mobile, if you're downloading JavaScript,
even if you're using LZ compression on the wire, that's cool,
but you've got to blow it out into memory and then parse the silly eight
character function keyword that I picked when I should've used something
shorter. I picked it because of all the Unix tool. Um.
So anyways, I'm not falling. I want to, but I'm not following the AUC thread.
Sorry. I said surprising to you that, uh, how fast JavaScript is these days.
I mean, like you've been through the whole journey. I know every,
every step of the way, but is it like, I mean, it's how it feels incredible.
It does, but I knew it. So the funny thing, yeah.
Computer science is this big karmic wheel, right? We all for tuna. Um,
and, uh, in the Smiths, the 97,
I was loaned by Netscape to do due diligence for sun in their
acquisition of anamorphic, which was, uh, David Unger, uh,
come in and friends, um, people, uh, Craig I'm forgetting his name.
He went to Microsoft, uh,
these Stanford language buffs who had taken smalltalk and then David create
itself as a simpler sort of smalltalk language and may really
fast just in time, compiling VMs for them. And they, you know,
well ahead of Java hotspot or JavaScript V8 or any of these modern BMS
figured out how to make dynamic code fast because smalltalk is dynamic
language, right? It has classes that has, I think, more lockdown, declarative,
syntax, and JavaScript, but it's fundamentally dynamic.
You don't have declared the types. Um,
but you could further types as the program runs and you start to form these
ideas about what types are actually flowing through key operations.
And you form a little tool called polymorphic inline caches that are
optimized machine code. The cash is the machine code that assumes,
does a quick check to make sure the type is right. And if it's not right,
it bails to the interpreter. And if it is right, you go pretty fast.
And that short test is a predicted branch. So things are,
things are pretty quick, all that amazing stuff I knew about in the nineties.
And I, I didn't have time to do it.
And anamorphic got bought by sun and they did hotspot.
And you needed that even in Java because at scale Java has some dynamic aspects
due to invoke interface.
You can have basically collections of Java code where you don't know at
the time of each, each module or package has compiled.
Exactly what's being called what the,
what subclass or what implementation of an interface is being called.
And so you want to optimize using the sort of dynamic polymorphic caching there
too. And they did that and hotspot, it's amazing, amazing beast.
I've met like 13 people who all claimed they created it. I think,
I think one of the, maybe deserve credit more than others. Um, but, uh,
I didn't get to do that in JavaScript.
And when we knew that that Google was going to do their own browser,
which we knew at Mozilla around 2006, um,
I also met the team that did V8 and it turns out it was Lars Bach,
who was one of the young engineers from anamorphic to got acquired by sun.
And so Lars is like the,
one of the world's expert on these kinds of virtual machines.
And he picked my brains about JavaScript.
I could tell he didn't like it at the time, but he had to do it. And Oh,
really interesting. Yeah. In 2006 lunch at Google's campus. Um, and,
and then I had other friends who was Devore at Chrome and he said, yeah,
we don't know what they're doing.
This is getting 2007 to fall getting towards 2008.
We're trying to get Chrome out.
And we don't know what's going on with the VA team.
They're often all who's Denmark, you know, rewriting their engine four times,
which is good. That's the right way to do this kind of development. You know,
they were learning JavaScript, including all its quirks,
which they came to hate the fire of a thousand suns,
which is one of the reasons that Lars and company did dart their own language,
but they also made the language fast. And meanwhile, we knew this was happening.
So we got our act together with, um, trace monkey,
our tracing jet at Mozilla and Apple, I think was also aware.
And so they were doing their own. So the era of jetted fast JavaScript in 2008,
had this prehistory going back to smalltalk itself and self and anamorphic.
And the, again,
the lineage is interesting because you had Lars and anamorphic and then he ends
up at Google.
Yeah. And today we have an incredibly fast language that,
like you said, still, you know, without hate you can't have love. So,
uh, I th I think there's both love and hate for this dance. Uh,
this rich complex dance of JavaScript throughout us history.